a photo finishing store charges
customers a rate of 29 cents
per photo to print pictures for new
customers the store offers a one-time
discount
of three dollars
write a function representing the amount
that a new customer would have to pay to
have x
number of photos printed so x is the
number of photos printed so just a
regular customer would have to pay the
number of photos times 29 cents a photo
so if we just said let y be the amount
that a customer would have to pay
a regular customer would have to pay
x times 29 cents per photo so we'd say
read write 0.29
we could put the dollar sign there if
you want
or 0.29 we're assuming everything in
dollars x that's how much a regular
customer would have to pay but they're
asking us a first time a new customer
and they say that the new customer gets
a one-time discount of three dollars so
a new customer will pay this
minus
minus three dollars so this there this
right here is
pretty much a simplified version of a
function that would describe what a new
customer would pay if you wanted to get
fancy this is a little bit inaccurate
when the customer ordered less than 10
photos because let's say the customer
orders 10 photos then x is going to be
10 times 29 cents is 2.90
minus 3 is negative 10 cents and the
customer's not going to not going to pay
negative 10 cents which would be like
the store paying them 10 cents for them
to print 10 photos the customer's not
going to pay anything so what we want to
do what we could do if we wanted to make
this a little bit fancier we could say
that
we could say that a new customer would
pay
new
customer
would
pay
and we would say that's y so y
is equal to
y is equal to
0.29 x minus 3
if
x is greater than 10 if the guy or the
gal orders more than 10 photos it's zero
otherwise
it's zero
otherwise then they don't pay anything
if it's less than 10 photos they pay
nothing it's not like the store is going
to pay them because
if you're less than 10 or 10 or less
actually then this is going to become
negative and we don't want a situation
where it's negative so they're either
going to pay nothing but if they get
more than 10 photos then they're going
to pay based on this function right
there